during the weeks-long process of picking  jurors in the trial of derrick chauvin  is pushed off a day the court first had  to deal with an appeal over the possible  reinstatement of a third degree murder  charge against the former minneapolis  police officer  who's already facing charges of  second-degree murder and manslaughter in  the death of george floyd  floyd's sister spoke outside the court  our hope is that justice prevails and we  can all use this  as an opportunity to be better  and do better for those around us  potential jurors answered questionnaires  to determine how much they knew about  the case  and their opinions about the protests  they also they're also being interviewed  individually opening arguments are  slated for march  29th